allez petit palais petit café oui
[Applaudissements]
ce commentaire de journalistes et
mythique dans le monde du rugby
mais aujourd'hui vu le gabarit des
joueurs difficile de dire allez petit le
rugby s'est professionnalisé en 1995
conséquence le jeu et les joueurs se
sont métamorphosés de quoi inquiéter le
médecin de l'équipe de france de
l'époque
d'autres fois vous aviez en première
ligne déjà un petit peu vent type au
tome qui se traînaient d'une mêlée en
touche et d'un regroupement un autre
maintenant vous avez des gens qui
courent comme des avions qui font un
sang 110-115 voir 125 kg qui court très
vite qu'ils se déplacent très vite ce
qui fait qu'au niveau des contacts ce ne
sont plus des des immeubles rencontre
mais ce sont des tgv qui se rencontrent
et tout simplement ça fait mal
les joueurs sont plus rapide plus
puissant plus musclée il suffit de
regarder le poids moyen des joueurs du
quinze de france
il ne fait qu'augmenter 96 kg en 1995
les joueurs français dépasser le quintal
en 2011 et atteignez même 104 kg en 2015
et pour sûr ce n'est pas la faute du
cassoulet mais plutôt de la fonte et
même des soupçons de dopage ces gabarits
impressionnants dans un jeu de contact
inquiéter un médecin neurologue
il mettait en garde sur les effets des
impacts et plus précisément sur les
séquelles des commotions cérébrales
le rugby est un très jeune sport
professionnel on n'a jamais vu un
développement musculaire aussi important
l'espace de plus de 20 ans on n'a jamais
vu un calendrier de matches aussi
développé en 20 ans par contre le
cerveau lui se développe pas il n'y a
pas de muscles autour du cerveau et donc
il faut bien voir qu'il ya des impacts
qui sont très très violent des alertes
qui ne cesseront de se répéter car le
jeu est de plus en plus frontale on
oublie les techniques d'évitement et les
deux tampons deviennent de plus en plus
violents oui je suis pas le premier à le
dire mais un jour nora mort soit par une
convention c'est vraiment être sévère
soit par un traumatisme abdominal ou
thoraciques pas ce que c'était et c'est
d'une extrême violence
cette funeste prédiction date de 2017 et
entre décembre 2018 et janvier 2019
quatre jeunes joueurs professionnels ou
non sont effectivement décédé suite à
des chocs sur le terrain
[Musique]